you know startups it's uh it's more like
an art
right than the science yeah
um
i think one thing is always thinking
about the go-to markets uh we as an
entrepreneur we tend to think too much
about the technology and do we have a
cool technology or not is it defensible
uh but sometimes you need to think how
i'm am i going to sell this uh product
uh and you need to think about it from
day one
exactly as you think about the algorithm
and
the code
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet idan
tenglo co-founder and ceo of bridge crew
udani is a serial entrepreneur vice
president of the devsecops product line
in the prisma cloud business unit at
palo alto networks he was previously
co-founder and ceo of bridge crew a
pioneer in cloud security solutions for
developers which was acquired by palo
alto networks in march of 2021 for 200
million dollars less than two years
after then it was founded
hedan was also the co-founder and ceo of
fort scale a leading user behavior
analytics startup which was acquired by
rsa security in 2018. before that he was
founder and head of the cyber security
business unit at lbeat systems israel's
leading defense integrator and served in
the idf's elite intelligence and cyber
unit 8200.
he done tender welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you thank you michael
i'm great thanks for hosting me here in
this romantic place i i i feel the same
way that you do and i i just love being
able to do this in person
especially knowing conversations like
this and we just had an amazing
conversation getting to know each other
and i'm really excited to now share with
a lot of my friends a little bit about
your own journey both as a person but
also as an entrepreneur today you're at
politi networks because
your startup bridge crew
with two amazing co-founders was
recently acquired by paluto
by just less than two years which is a
story on its own uh before that with
fourth scale your other startup uh and
and we share a lot in common in general
so i'm just happy to do this
conversation together me too tell me a
little bit about who you are as edan who
you know in your core who who is he done
wow uh so i'm from richon you know i was
born and raised in richolizion in israel
and i just came back
from like seven years in san francisco
in the bay area yeah but i'm you know
eventually i'm from ritual eventually
from richon yeah
an engineer entrepreneur
thinker
what what how do you define yourself
these days like a dad a husband
entrepreneur
and a leader i guess what does that mean
to you
you know from from the day i remember
myself
i wanted to do things differently
i wanted to you know change
the
i guess the status quo
of things only now i see it in
retrospect interesting um
is it mainly in technology or do you
also see that in in real world you know
when i was kid when i was in unit a200
uh
it wasn't about technology it was about
teams and it was about building
processes and about
building new projects uh because i'm not
coming from a technological background
right so this is why i never saw myself
as an entrepreneur you know i have an
uncle which i
admire and he is coming from the
entrepreneurship world
but he has a background in hardware like
very very technology so when i was a kid
i said wow that's cool but i would never
be an entrepreneur
because i'm not that into technology i
was into i don't know arabic and the
politics and then the building stuff
uh and again only in retrospect i think
i was actually
an entrepreneur so you're not just an
entrepreneur you're a multi your serial
entrepreneur with now two stars behind
you and who knows what will happen in
the future
what makes that leap so how do you go
from saying i i don't think i'll be an
entrepreneur too you know building
fourth scale then spending time hiking
you mentioned to figure out what company
you want to build next
yeah so you know
life just i guess what happened
so after i finished my military service
in unit a200 i started to learn
engineering but it was industrial
engineering so it wasn't like a real
engineering as my wife says
and
i just um
i i did a couple of gigs uh in the vc
world actually in l.o uh so i for the
first time i saw myself meeting ceos and
founders it was really cool but the
first real conversation opportunity i
got was uh from the head of unit a200 uh
yeah your coin i knew him we worked
together in the past and he's just
started you know i'm talking about 2009.
wow it just started to work in
lbit which is like the biggest you know
defense integrator in israel and he told
me yeah tender well you know you should
come here let's do something around
cyber security and to be honest i knew
what is cyber more from not from the
security part from the other part from
my military service but i didn't know
what is cyber security uh and he said
yeah you should just join and i know i
also didn't
think i would work in a defense industry
right right but
it was like a good opportunity and a
good challenge and i just joined it was
just me
and a laptop wow
and for couple of months we just
prepared what should we do and after two
years it was a group of final 70 80
people that i led
and we became one of the fastest a
growth engine of this huge company and
we dealt with cyber security sold
millions of dollars across the world
and one day
um one guy that i worked with came into
my room i remember it and he told me
idan you should have
your own startup
and this is where i said oh actually
this is what i'm doing here that's
actually what yeah i'm building a
startup
but in a bigger hope
the next day i just quit
actually yeah
and
we
we built actually together our first
startup and that was a full scale
unbelievable
tell me a little bit about you know not
not necessarily
the journey of fourth skill but
if you know moving from one startup to
the next having spent meaningful time
with fort scale and being you know very
thoughtful person what are some of the
key takeaways as you transition into or
you started bridge crew and specifically
how do you think those that impacted you
know the trajectory of bridge crew which
obviously was an amazing success
wow so yeah foursquare was a long
journey of uh i know five six years uh
we were in very deep area of security
finding insider threats like you know
finding edward snowden that was in the
nsa finding it
in your company in your bank
uh we raised you know more than 20
million dollars but it was very very
challenging journey we had
you know amazing experience we had cisco
we had yahoo
as customers
but it was challenging and eventually we
were acquired by rsa security uh but it
was like uh not that good of an exit
and i didn't join i would say security
and uh i decided that i need to take
like some time off and
back then i i was living in san
francisco
uh i had two kids now i have three
and i just started to hike
literally yeah yeah i think i know every
hill every mountain in the bay area like
give me three hours from san francisco
i've been there
um
and i just hiked so you would wake up
go to a hill there i flew the kids
usually as a school
and just took some food usually
chocolate chip cookies and went hiking
not for the physical
aspect of it or no i just
heard some good music
uh sometimes i took good friends with me
sometimes
mainly it was by myself
and then i started actually writing wow
so i brought like a paper and a pen
uh and then a laptop and i just started
writing and i i just started writing you
know the key lessons
that i learned from the thoughts get
experience so we started with all the
good things like uh
bring good customers bring good visas
and then
the bad things
but then
it became personal so what
what did i do which was good and what
did i do that was really wrong
because of me
because i'm a person eventually
and it took me a couple of months to
reach
that
that level
i knew that i want to do another startup
it burned like really really hard inside
my heart
but i didn't know exactly
in which area actually i didn't want to
do it in security wow
i wanted to do other things um
and then a year later i founded bridge
crew why what was the thought of
straying away from security was it
mainly to experience something else
so first yeah i wanted to you know i i
saw myself as an entrepreneur as a ceo
as a manager as a leader not necessarily
as a security
professional and i said okay i want to
you know give me a new challenge
and another thing in security
usually the majority of security
companies they try to sell some fear
all right you have to buy us unless the
north koreans will come right and i
didn't like it i wanted to do something
more positive okay it's a more positive
value by the way eventually bridge
school
we did sell a positive value we just
came to developers right and we said hey
we will help you we will help you to be
more effective and to be more efficient
right
so
in that case yeah we did security
eventually but it was positive so we're
talking about the you know ceo and
leadership and entrepreneurship
now you mentioned as we were walking and
i was shocked that you
you're not a developer yourself
you don't really write code
and never write a single line of code
never wrote a single i know that i'm
proud of it because
effectively you've built a tool
that was very effectively helping
developers you know you both went into
the open source world and i spoke with
barack quite a bit about it and it
sounds like an incredible journey a way
to lead that journey is by truly
understanding you know developers and
not just their day job but how they
think and how they act
but then creating a product that that
actually worked and and you leading this
this mothership and being the captain of
it how does that work without not
knowing how to write a single line of
code uh sometimes it's a disadvantage
but sometimes it's an advantage first of
all in bridge crew you know i founded it
with barack and guy yeah well amazing
right you know and they are amazing with
their capabilities and technical
background and uh
we complement each other a lot uh
and this is one thing i didn't feel that
i missed
this background but second i just know
which questions i guess
to ask
and i know
who should i ask it so the first thing i
did and then we did it together we just
interviewed
a lot of people we interviewed something
like 100
security managers csos
before
we developed something
wow
and that was actually one of the
conclusions you remember my hiking that
was one of the lessons learned never
write a product without being certain
that somebody will actually use it
and um
we did it and when you talk to so many
people from diverse you know backgrounds
and big companies small companies then
you started to
you start to feel to hear what they
actually need
and i think this was an advantage i i
brought to the table from day one wow so
in your if you're looking at the
day-to-day of running bridge group for
the very short amount of time that that
it went on which is the amazing piece of
it
how did you you know balance
the experiences you had with with your
co-founders
so very very different experiences very
different strengths and weaknesses
did you have a lot of conversations
about it were you all very intentional
about it on who makes what decision and
how much information because obviously
sometimes maybe barack would have an
idea
and to back it up he would have to go
and explain it on this tangent and why
the developers will love it
how much of those did you need to have
in order to be effective in leading this
company
yeah it's a great question i'm not sure
i thought enough about it i guess it's
like a marriage like uh you know being a
couple uh each one is bringing something
else to the table and it's all about
chemistry right it was clear from day
one that i'm more the outbound voice i'm
bringing the customers i'm bringing the
investors i'm bringing the advisors
i'm telling the story of who we are
uh and it was very clear that guy who is
a brilliant product
manager and this and vp of product
is leading the product and decides
what actually are we building and it was
clear that barack is the genius that the
cto that uh
you know brings the open source and
building the community around it and
actually create the first
uh engineering team right and it was
clear i'm not sure even we talked about
it wow it was very clear but also it's
like marriage it's personalities usually
i'm passionate and i'm driving let's do
this
and guys say hey let's wait like two
weeks uh before we do that uh
and barak is thinking whether it's
actually could be done right so we
balance each other also with that
on your next journey let's say about
another company at some point
what is maybe one or two things that
you're gonna come in with real
conviction that you're saying like no
matter what this is what i know and this
is how i want to run this whether if
it's about the team about the market
about fundraising what what is something
that you're coming into this next step
really with your like your kishke
burning
so wow i think um
you know startups it's uh it's more like
an art
right than the science yeah
um
i think one thing is always thinking
about the go-to markets we as
entrepreneur we tend to think too much
about the technology and uh do we have a
cool technology or not is it defensible
uh but sometimes you need to think how
am i going to sell this
product uh and you need to think about
it from day one
exactly as you think about the algorithm
and
the code
and this is something i'm super super
passionate about uh
building a strategy and thesis of the go
to market in our case it was bottom-up
it was product-led growth which was
really unique yeah i think we were one
of the first
companies yeah i've only been hearing
about it the last two three years
properly which is and right around the
time you started yeah i mean usually
security you're sitting top down right
you're going to the cso you scare him
and then you're getting a deal of 200
in our case we understood that the
persona the user
is not the security officer is the
developer and right they don't care
about security no and if they do they
will never you know run a poc a proof of
concept or they will never pay you a big
check
they will try
they want to try it by themselves and
maybe they will pay you 100 dollars it's
a very very it's like the opposite model
and we understood that we need to copy
uh models of slack
and of twilio companies that really did
it in a plg in a product-led growth mode
uh we didn't have too many models in
security so we needed to copy them but
to translate that to you know to the
security world to the devops world
take me back a little bit a lot take me
back a lot elementary school middle
school
young youngidan yeah what fascinates you
first of all my hair
i had definitely more hair back
most people that i have on the show they
they say well i was an engineer i used
to take things apart i used to code from
five years old
not necessarily the case here what
really fascinated you in the day today
so actually a lot of things i uh i had a
lot of imagination and i like to build
stuff sometimes physical stuff like
sometimes i took my playmobil and built
cities inside my room
and i didn't let anybody anyone
including my sister to to go in so it
was more like a secret
and then i wrote my first newspaper
it was i think just for me maybe for the
neighbors
then for the school
and then you know i decided i need to be
in the student council although there
was not a student council back then in
my school which was like one of the
biggest schools in israel
uh in rishon
so i i built it and actually i became
the chairman
of this council
and it was
always around you know
uh learning new new stuff uh one day i i
decided i need to learn arabic i think
it was like the eighth or ninth grade
wow uh really it was really important
for me um still i just learned
yeah
okay uh and you know i really wanted to
do that but also to be
to be with other people right yeah to
get to know other people but only i
think only in unit a200
maybe you feel the same
when i joined i felt like really home
for the first time i saw people that
were more like me
sometimes much better than me
and i think this is the moment that i
you know
i felt really good with myself
now if you look today and not not like
beyond bridge crew and fourth scale if
you look today and what inspires you
either you know generally in this world
or
or inspires you to think differently
about the world well what is it
is it the ability to do stuff as an
entrepreneur
family
problems in the world what what inspires
you well relax first of all i'm now a vp
in palo alto so we're doing the same
thing yeah that we did before but now in
the bigger right corporate and i own
that and it's funny you know palo alto
is
you know selling more than four billion
dollar a year but probably not a single
dollar is coming from a credit card wow
we are the first
machine in palo alto networks that
actually
you could buy with a credit card and
building a bottom up motion in this huge
company it's that's amazing experience
and actually i love it a lot
you know
i love
challenges
not only technological but also people
how do you build a bigger team in a
bigger organization
and we just came back to israel so maybe
the third thing is uh
we just came back with the family after
seven years in san francisco or three
three kids three kids uh young kids
crazy amazing
and we feel again like immigrants
wow
we know this space we love it we have
families and friends and you know we
have jerusalem and but we feel like
different because we're coming with the
experience we had in the bay area which
is more or less the opposite right you
know that
uh
so it's
it's fascinating
to me to see how we do that
well one of the things that i have to
say that really inspired me before we
started this episode is we talked about
the transition to israel and one of the
things that you mentioned was that
it was such an a strong intrinsic
conviction that you had as a family this
is where you want to be
and not necessarily because you agree
with politics or because you agree with
what's happening in fact we both share
the fact that there are things that we
don't agree with but
the fact that at the end it's some
there's something there's something so
strong inside of us
that pulls you i think that's something
very very special and i gained a lot of
motivation of that for me and for a lot
of people that i know that are very
conflicted with these thoughts yeah so i
was i didn't see myself as conflicted
i insisted that my kids will talk hebrew
and we were israelis we celebrated all
the not only the jewish holidays but the
you know the yamato independence day
yeah and it was all about israel and
israeli song and culture uh but
eventually they were americans
right and i they grew up there yeah yeah
and i was into you know
one day my mom called me did you see
what happened in politics or whatever
and of course i saw i'm i'm hearing
galetsa like more than you right
i mean twitter i was really really
but then we said okay maybe now it's
time following the acquisition maybe now
that was time for us to go back right uh
and i remember that we took the kids uh
you know one of them was two years old
but the
back then seven years old we told her
hey we consider moving back to israel
and i remember that she
she immediately started crying
and the first thing she said
can i will i see him the family
and i understood that
she was waiting for that for her entire
life wow without us even telling her
that one day we will be back in israel
she knew
in her back of her mind
that it's temporary wow i'm about to cry
here then
it's amazing
what are a few words you would use to
describe yourself
uh probably
passionate yeah
as i mentioned
caring
a
leader and friendly
i i'll take all of those a hundred
percent it done
thank you very very much i can't wait
for what what you do now at palo alto
network is the vice president there and
for whatever else you do whether it's in
the private sector or any other sector i
i just can't wait thank you very very
much thank you thanks michael